the crisis has shown that it is absolutely necessary for
a monetary zone to be able to ensure the
convergence of its member states to
prevent these economies from diverging
because when you have only one
currency you cannot afford to
have economies that diverge kits for
example  in terms of corporation
tax in terms of minimum wages
in terms of investment levels,
if there is an asymmetric shock
, i.e. they affect
one member state in particular in seven to
member  can react and that all
the member states
help it to react because if it is
reached all the others are too,
so it is not in the interest of the other
member countries of the euro zone to
let go  all
one's breath is held hostage we are holding a symmetrical shock that concerns the
entire zone, for example a rise in the
price of oil
I am brutal in the level
of investment in the
activity the euro zone as a whole must be
able to have a steering tool  of
his  hospital practice in africa
if we don't make red strong if we do
n't make the euro stable if we don't
equip to learn from the crisis and
to face future challenges and much
more from europe
[Music]